Julian got some face time with a bunch
of stars at the Hollywood Foreign Press
Association in Grant's banquet including
James Corden who reacted to the social
media backlash calling the cat's trailer
creepy I think for everyone that was in
it it was in such a shock if you're not
familiar with the musical Cats then yeah
it's gonna be quite a ship up I've never
had more fun shooting anything and yeah
I can't wait for people to see it we
also caught up with business star Justin
Hartley who gave us deep it's on season
four we are currently like halfway
through episode two in last season's
finale we saw a flash-forward with
Justin's TV son
hey where's your dad assume you already
know who Kevin babymama
but you know like I would presume that
you're trying to get me to tell you I'm
really good at this now I can't wait for
you to see this from Renee Zellweger to
Arnold Schwarzenegger the event was
filmed the stars who helped give out 3.8
million dollars in grants and
scholarships it's also where Josh Lucas
told us this about a sweet home alabama'
see I'm up for it I know Reese's said
she is as well you owe me a dance so
look I throw it out series it has to
happen my only must-haves for the sequel
is there has to be a baby in a bomb
you